what is Magnus Carlson's birthday I
believe November 30th you know the year
well I'm 87 and he's part of that next
Generation so it should be
1990 where was Magnus Carlson born now
this one is tricky because I I get these
cities confused it's tburg right it's
tburg that's what it is at what age did
Magnus Carlson become a Grandmaster it's
getting younger that should be it's 13
or 14 I'm pretty sure it was at 13 years
old what is magnus's favorite opening
move in over theboard games I'm going to
assume it's E4 but I honestly don't know
correct he's played E4 762 times and D4
555 times Magnus recently co-authored a
chess book who did he co-author it with
and what is the title I don't know the
title but it's a book with like David
Howell mhm grind like a
Grandmaster one of magnus's first
sponsors was a clothing company what was
that company those are the very early
days company would be gar wrong which TV
show did Magnus Carlson appear in 2017 I
believe that would be the Simpsons nice